jpmorgan maybe in some hot water the new
york-based Bank new federal authorities
were investigating millennium health LLC
that is the largest drug testing lab in
the US it said nothing that kind of a
mission would in most markets be
regarded as unethical or perhaps illegal
Bloomberg Lord Bloomberg's Laura Keller
reported the story she joins me now what
obligation legally was JP Morgan under
to pass this information on well we've
reported that JPMorgan felt it was not
under an obligation to do so what
governs these loan agreements especially
when they're sold for the material
omission is you know more statutory law
common law it's not there's no se SI and
forcing you've got it as was this it has
to be there it's very much Wild West is
it standard practice that if the company
says this is a material the bank is
under no obligation to think about
whether it should decide whether it's
material or not well I mean the bankers
a hired as an advisor right and they
deal with these lenders from deal to
deal to deal so while maybe there isn't
a legal mode for them to have to
disclose it on behalf of the company
even if the company doesn't want you
certainly you know there's an onus on
them to maintain a relationship with
lenders who are gonna continue to buy a
deal and if those lenders can't trust
the agent that's hired for its expertise
in marketing the deal that becomes a bit
of a problem in sales right well this is
a great great story because you really
actually went into the broader scale
here it does seem like that this is a
low interest rate environment phenomenon
yes I'm it's partly you know lender
protections go away when when companies
can just sell whatever they want to sell
this company for example I mean this is
a dividend yield right which is a risky
deal to begin with it was seventy-five
percent of the proceeds used for a
dividend which essentially means yeah
you as a lender gave the company money
and the company took that money and gave
it to shareholders that's it's a riskier
thing that a lot of lenders don't
usually in the restaurant industry they
call that a kickback I think there are
different names in different industries
is that it's very nicely you know I
really did that well thank you Oh walk
through some of these these other
conditions you know we talked about the
Wild West I was shocked to read in your
piece blacklists right yeah we've been
reading a lot about these blacklist I
mean these are this is
something you can do in an equity market
this is not something you can do in the
bond market where your public people can
buy you and I we can so we can buy it
when we want in the loan market you
actually have the company able to say
well look we don't want these kind of
people in sometimes you know it's for
reasons you can understand where it's
it's a competitor you don't want them to
get your projections and that's what
lenders get but other times it's to keep
out people I usually report on which is
the distressed debt worlds because they
end up sticking up for creditor
protection but really I mean the reason
the people that lenders are willing to
accept these conditions is that this
debt is what there is to hold this is
where the returns are right yes exactly
and and this is more of a high-yield
sort of situation right i mean it's a
loan but it pays pretty well for a loan
so i think some people would argue for
the risk that's there now it doesn't but
it's at the time you know that seems to
be an attractive interest rate and it
was actually bumped up at the time of
the sale is what you hear across markets
we had no choice we had to do it we
needed you needed to put our money
somewhere right so these are the
opportunities that exist we exerted a
little bit of control over the issuer we
got a better interest rate at the
beginning but now we're faced with all
these problems you know we don't know
what you do with this company anymore
right so you were sitting on all this
cash this is the nicest mattress in the
guest house um when rates change do we
expect as anyone told you that some of
this behavior is gonna go away I think
it naturally starts to dissipate right i
mean once you have more control as a
lender it naturally has to dissipate
okay anybody else who are the companies
that are actually from the filings that
you've read actually involved there is a
legal action right well no there's
nothing filed at this point we've
reported that the lenders have formed a
group they're trying to figure out you
know what they want to do going forward
um you know you can start to think about
securing to default you know looking at
the loan document saying what did you as
the company need to disclose did you
violate this are you in technical
default and if this is not an SEC action
it's a statutory law action does this
end up in New York courts and I think
the New York Court is what governs us
it's literally you know you could be
covered my Delaware law just depends i'm
not sure where there's okay